bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 25 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
l'élection du nouveau président de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines approche de
candidats se présentent pour ce poste
didier guillemot enseignants chercheurs
et médecins est l'un des candidats il
sera notre invité ce soir
une initiative originale chronique d'une
ville c'est le projet mis en place par
la mairie de plaisir et j'ai cheval
écrivain et journaliste il recueille les
témoignages des plaisirs wave à leur
rencontre afin d'en faire un livre
enfin en sport le fc versailles est
actuellement la quatrième place du
championnat de division d'honneur
l'accession à l'échelon supérieur
l'objectif fixé en début de saison
semble compromis mais l'entraîneur de
l'équipe du cfc chili veut toujours y
croire
ce sera l'objet de notre chronique sport
et les chiffres du chômage ont été
communiqués hier au mois de janvier le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi de
catégorie à a baissé de 0 6% dans les
yvelines
ce sont désormais 60 4100 personnes qui
sont dans ce cas un chiffre en
augmentation de 2,8 pour cent sur un an
en ile-de-france toujours pour le mois
de janvier la baisse est de 0,2 pour
cent et l'augmentation du nombre de
chômeurs de cette catégorie de 2 7% sur
un an sur un an toujours dans les
yvelines la hausse pour les trois
catégories réunies et de 5,4 pour cent
toutefois les données de janvier sont
difficiles à analyser car le nombre de
personnes qui sont sorties des
catégories a b c pour défaut
d'actualisation de leur dossier a fait
un bond inexpliquée et dimanche 21
février marisol touraine ministre de la
santé a annoncé vouloir mettre à table
et en application une augmentation forte
et significative du prix du tabac le
plus vite possible
elle s'est même dit favorable à un
paquet à 10 euros tout en reconnaissant
que ce ne serait pas sous ce quinquennat
actuellement le prix moyen d'un paquet
de cigarettes est de 7 euros dans les
yvelines
les professionnels craignent le
développement grandissant du marché
parallèle écoutez c'est de la
provocation c'est pour cacher d'autres
mesures qui n'arrive pas à tenir et que
quand on parle du tabac on parle pas
d'autre chose
on n'est pas contre la politique de
santé publique ce qu'on veut c'est que
on n'est pas 25 à 30% de tabac de
contrebande
vendue au noir sous le manteau on veut
que tout absolument du genou c'est tout
ce qu'on réclame et je vous disais en
titre cette année l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
fête ses 25 ans mais un autre événement
va également marqué cette année 2007 et
l'élection du nouveau président de
l'université
elle aura lieu le 24 mars prochain en
lice de candidat jean-luc vestiaires
actuels présidents d'université et
didier guillemot deuxième candidat il
est avec nous sur ce plateau ce soir
bonsoir à vous merci merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors vous êtes
en chine enseignant chercheur à
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines également
médecin
pourquoi vous présenter à cette élection
consentant motivation à tout d'abord je
voudrais vous remercier de l'invitation
je regrette que le débat n'ait pas pu
être organisée avec le président sortant
je crois que c'est un exercice
démocratique de démocratie universitaire
et ce débat il est vraiment on sera
reçue prochainement peut-être un débat
sera organisé mais pour l'instant c'est
juste
alors pourquoi pourquoi ma candidature
et pourquoi initiative et bien
simplement parce que l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin notre
université est d'une certaine manière en
dormance il y as d'une d'un côté
l'université paris saclay dont nous
sommes
membre fondateur et puis il y as d'un
autre côté le département des yvelines
avec son monde économique son monde
social ça fait les deux polarités de
l'université il faut que l'université
versailles saint quentin soit
initiatrice soit force de propositions
voire même un peu aiguillon dans paris
saclay pour que paris saclay tourner son
regard vers nous et puis il faut que
nous développions que nous renforcions
que nourdine à vision les partenariats
avec le monde économique
c'est la mission voilà de l'université
que d'être tourné vers l'extérieur alors
parler sa classe et un beau grand enjeu
désistement de cette élection
quels sont les autres enjeux justement
pour universel à saint quentin pour vous
alors il ya paris saclay évidemment
c'est à dire qu'il faut que nous créions
une force motrice et que nous arrêtions
de suivre d'être passif dans paris
saclay nous avons beaucoup d'initiatives
individuelles enseignants chercheurs
mais il faut que la présidence le choeur
de l'université portent ces initiatives
de façon résolue alors je dirais que
c'était que faut-il pour l'université
versailles je pense que nous avons
besoin en premier lieu de revoir un peu
la gouvernance il faut une gouvernance
horizontale gels usage de dire qu'au
fond la présidente j'aime pas trop le
mot fait le coeur de l'université est
bien est une composante comme une autre
avec des fonctions différentes mais
doivent jouer un rôle d'animation
d'initiation aller chercher de l'argent
de partenariats avec d'autres voilà déjà
ça c'est très important
les choses se passent pas comme ça en ce
moment la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
nous faut une stratégie toutes les
universités du monde qu'elle soit grande
petite nous sommes de taille humaine ont
un plan stratégique qui évolue
évidemment eh bien nous nous n'avons pas
nous avons
voilà une déclaration d'intention un peu
factuel dans le cadre du contrat avec
l'état mais il nous faut vraiment
réfléchir une stratégie en deux ce
serait restaurant un moyen de pour paris
saclay de se rattacher un gros pôle
universitaire parce que vous êtes en
concurrence avec beaucoup d'universités
je pense notamment à cergy pontoise ou
alors à des universités parisiennes
comme la sorbonne et finalement au fur
et à mesure des années peut-être une
partie des recettes encore on n'a pas
réussi
il n'y a pas de concurrence il y a une
dynamique propre
il faut que nous spécifions probablement
que nous retrouvions un peu d'identité
et que nous raisonnions en termes de
partenariat la concurrence et est un mot
qui n'existe pas vraiment il faut
trouver les synergies avec d'autres
universités avec cergy pontoise aussi
nous avons déjà des objets en commun je
pense à l'institut d'études politiques
par exemple qui est vraiment une belle
formation
et puis avec d'autres universités voire
même de les écoles de paris saclay et
que nous travaillons avec eux de façon à
développer nos recherches nos
innovations informations une des
problématiques de l'université de
versailles d'un conte de 50 ans divine
c'est justement sont peut-être d'unités
sur le territoire au niveau
universitaire ça qu'il ya beaucoup de
poules différent il faut la rassembler
ça fait partie de vos objectifs
également alors on pourrait qualifier ça
d'entropie géographie qui est grande
elle est naturellement grande
rambouillet
mantes-la-ville mantes la jolie saint
germain saint quentin en yvelines vélizy
versailles évidemment l'idée n'est pas
de regrouper géographiquement parce que
ses différentes composantes lyrique leur
territoire ont une vraie fonction
notamment une fonction autour des
étudiants qui sont là nos étudiants et
notre polarité notre vocation elle est
sûre les yvelines et il n'y a aucune
raison de regrouper tout ce monde dans
un même lieu géographique par contre il
faut recréer une vie de l'université une
vie sociale de l'université au sein des
sites il y en a déjà mais entre les
sites aussi et puis facilités de
circulation
je pense par exemple aux enseignants
chercheurs qui son amante faire en sorte
qu'il soit facile pour eux de faire de
la recherche
je pense par exemple aussi aux étudiants
on va essayer de réfléchir et de
travailler à comment mieux circuler
entre les différentes composantes
notamment si on développe des
initiatives de licence qui pourrait être
multidisciplinaire par exemple justement
des double licence dit master d'assises
c'est le il faut accentuer sa à oui je
crois qu'il faut vraiment les doubles
licences ce sont des formations
extrêmement intéressante je pense qu'on
a besoin d'eux dans le futur de jeunes
qui sont formés avec différents
background différentes disciplines
c'est fondamental dans l'évolution des
métiers de demain vous dit que
universités que l'on n'a pas de projets
c'est un reproche que vous faites à
l'actuel président jean nécessaires
c'est à dire c'est pas un reproche il y
a eu ce qu'on a appelé la crise mais la
crise n'était pas un prétexte à essayer
de
redynamiser les énergies individuelles
collectives
c 'est la fonction du coeur de
l'université que d'essayer de travailler
de redonner de l'énergie collective
c'est pas un reproche c'est comme ça je
regarde pas le passé
je regarde plutôt le futur et c'est
vraiment ce à quoi je vais m'employer
est justement parce qu'ils diffèrent
entre vos deux projets celui de monsieur
nasser et j'irai cas de vision il ya
probablement une vision un peu du passé
de l'université je ne prendrai qu'un
seul exemple la manière dont les
étudiants participent à la vie de
l'université
pour ce qui me concerne je considère que
l'université est une communauté
d'enseignants d'enseignants chercheurs
de personnels biatoss le mot est pas
beau et d'étudiants qui concourent
savoir qui le construisent des étudiants
font partie de l'université en sont les
acteurs
ce ne sont pas des élèves sont ne sont
pas plus des lycéens
il faut que cette communauté vivent
ensemble et construire construire de
savoir en commun est-ce que aussi par
exemple dans l'université la formation
aux professionnels ou parler de
partenariat aller vers le monde
économique les acteurs économiques de
notre territoire ça fait partie aussi
des points importants c'est absolument
essentiel dans la formation il y à des
chantiers notamment la question des
licences dans le cadre de paris saclay
mais je mets au coeur de ma proposition
du programme tout d'abord la question de
ce qu'on appelle la formation tout au
long de la vie nous savons que les
métiers sont évolutifs nous savons même
que les individus vont avoir plusieurs
métiers c'est ce qui se passe déjà aux
etats-unis 3 4 et bien il faut que notre
université soit résolu à développer la
formation des offres de formation tout
au long de la vie qui mieux qu'une
université peut le faire alors même
qu'elle a des enseignants chercheurs des
unités de recherche qui sont en mesure
d'anticiper ce qui va se faire dans le
futur
eh bien il faut que nous soyons que nous
soyons là et si nous ne sommes pas là et
bien d'autres vont le faire évidemment
des officines qui n'ont pas de missions
de service public
ce sont des projets ambitieux qui
demandent justement de l'argent le
problème la station financière de la
faculté avait fait beaucoup de bruit
voilà il ya quelques années
c'est au bord de la faillite aujourd'hui
la station est revenu à l'équilibré
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour éviter
une telle situation est ce qu'on n'a pas
besoin d'être d'un gestionnaire à la
tête
je pense qu'à la tête d'une université
il faut quelqu'un qui se projette dans
le futur qui mieux qu'un enseignant
chercheur universitaire de haut niveau
scientifique peut le faire la fonction
d'un président c'est d'indiquer la
direction du vent est de savoir là où
nous allons aller collectivement et
d'animer le collectif ensuite
effectivement il faut dans une diversité
des gens qui sont de bon gestionnaire il
n'y a absolument aucun doute
alors vous abordiez comment
éventuellement retrouver où trouver de
l'argent accès à l'extérieur parce que
c'est un enjeu pour universités et vous
savez du côté de la formation tout au
long de la vie ou du côté des
technologies de l'information et de la
communication pour l'éducation qu'il va
falloir réanimer d'une certaine manière
dans notre université
eh bien il ya des possibilités d'appel
d'offres nationaux voire internationaux
et la présidence le choeur de
l'université ne doit jouer comme toutes
les universités dans le monde est bien
allé chercher ses financements
vous êtes enseignant chercheur je sais
que forcément la recherche est très
importante pour vous lu vs tués contre
il ya cinq ans au classement de shanghai
des 505 sont bien établis sements
mondiaux supérieur de recherche est ce
qu'il est possible avec des budgets qui
sont quand même limité de conserver
justement cette ambition au niveau de la
recherche au sein de il faut c'est
indispensable
à défaut de redynamisation
un des risques c'est que petit à petit
notre recherche se délite que les gens
partent vous savez puis et que le
rayonnement scientifique soit soient
moindres c'est indispensable pour
pouvoir assurer un dynamisme de
formation une existence et même un
dynamisme de formation dans les cycles
de licence il faut que ces les
enseignants que les chercheurs aient
bien en scène que les
enseignants-chercheurs phase de la
recherche dans des unités du meilleur
niveau qui soit et notamment des unités
labellisés par les organismes je pense
au cnrs je pense à l'inserm
je pense au ceva je pense que naissent
aussi le spatial et en quelque chose
d'absolument incroyable dans notre
université je pense à l'inra enfin bref
d'autres et j'en oublie
c'est un moyen des lois de serre et
peut-être de nouveaux professeurs
peut-être des profits si on peut dire à
absolument c'est essentiel d'essayer de
redonner à notre université une
attractivité vis-à-vis de collègues
français mais pourquoi pas deux
collègues internationaux ou européens il
y en a déjà
et c'est effectivement la recherche
effectivement un élément qui permet
d'être attractif à des gens du meilleur
niveau qui soit merci à didier
évanescente replâtrer d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je le rappelle donc
l'élection du nouveau président de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines aura lieu le 24 mars prochain
nous suivrons bien évidemment cette
actualité chien tout autre sujet à
présent depuis lundi la moitié des
employés de la société de transport
keolis sont en grève les grévistes ont
bloqué le dépôt de bus empêchant tout
service minimum pour satisfaire les
habitants de la ville de vélizy
villacoublay les élus ont décidé
d'assurer eux-mêmes un service minimum
depuis ce matin 5 bus sont conduits par
les élus de la ville depuis la station
robert wagner jusqu'à la gare de
chaville vélizy n'écoutez en a émis 5
véhicules à disposition des véhicules de
la ville et ce sont les élus qui se
mobilisent depuis ce matin d'accord pour
répondre aux attentes et visions et des
salariés surtout on fait le lien entre
le tramway et la gare de chelles et
vélizy les gens comment ils ont pris la
chose très surpris et très très
agréablement surpris donc très content
d'avoir cette réponse ce matin et de se
dire que ce soir ils peuvent compter sur
nous c'est bien mais ça aurait été plus
réactifs ceux ci en avait eu ça en début
de semaine pour avoir ce qui nous donne
l'opportunité de monter en voiture bras
le corps suit gratuit gratifiant est à
noter que depuis une heure la société
kéolis assure assure de nouveau un
service minimum bien que les élus
continueront à assurer le transport des
riverains pour la journée de demain est
à présent nous en parler d'une
initiative originale si les habitants de
plaisir raconter leur ville que
dirait-il chronique d'une ville un
projet mis en place par la ville de
plaisir et gilles cheval un écrivain
journaliste depuis plus depuis plusieurs
mois il va à la rencontre des plaisirs
oit pour recueillir leurs témoignages de
ces rencontres va naître prochainement
un livre sur la ville l'histoire de
plaisir à travers les yeux de ses
habitants regarder si gilles cheval et
si bien reçu
c'est qu'il commence à être familier des
plaisirs roy écrivain et journaliste il
va leur rencontre depuis le mois de
septembre pour recueillir leurs
histoires et anecdotes de précieuses
informations pour raconter à travers
leurs récits la ville de plaisir dans un
livre aujourd'hui c'est au tour de
claude de lui livrer ses souvenirs j'ai
connu mais c'était que deschamps faire
raconter aux gens des choses qui les ont
marqués
un lien avec la ville ou amusant
certains habitants ont manifesté leur
désir de raconter leur ville auprès de
la mairie de plaisir à l'origine de
cette initiative
mais pour rencontrer plus de témoins
gilles est aussi allé dans des lieux de
vie comme les écoles les maisons de
retraite ou encore la bibliothèque
la plupart des témoins répondent
toujours quand on les aborde qui n'ont
pas de souvenirs qu'ils n'ont pas
d'idées et finalement au bout de cinq
minutes on peut plus les arrêter
c'est la première année qu'on voit ça
j'aurais vraiment participé à ce livre
ça va représenter en fait ce qui est
vraiment plaisir finalement 1 entre le
passé et le présent et l'avenir
publiée cet été le livre sera donnée aux
témoins et mise à disposition des
plaisirs hu a tiré de la mémoire
collective levrat aussi pour but de
raconter l'histoire nationale à travers
l'histoire locale
j'ai notamment quelques témoignages sur
la guerre de 39 45
donc là on est vraiment dans l'histoire
nationale et c'est fabuleux de savoir de
quelle manière s'est passé vraiment ici
à plaisir et comment les gens ont vécu
cette période
un projet culturel qui ne s'arrête pas
au papier mise en scène et en musique
par le conservatoire d'art dramatique
plusieurs institutions théâtrales sont
prévues tout au long de l'année
nouvelle saison nouveau spectacle pour
l'académie équestre de versailles les
écuyers de bartabas remonte en selle
dans le manège de la grande écurie du
château royal pour un nouvel opus du
spectacle la voie de l'écuyer un
spectacle enrichie cette année avec de
l'attelage
ils ont repris en musique le chemin du
manège les huit écuyers et leurs chevaux
à nouveau réunis dans un ballet
envoûtant et chorégraphié par bartabas
le spectacle la voie de l'écuyer existe
depuis 2003 mais chaque année il
s'enrichit au gré des envies et des
expériences de la compagnie
l'attelage c'est la grande nouveauté de
cette saison une discipline nouvelle
pour les chevaux et pour les écuyers il
leur a fallu un nom pour mettre ce
tableau en place il ya plus de
mouvements possibles les chevaux une
fois adressé peuvent pas fait pire
aurait été sous la voiture et tourner
autour de son axe que peuvent pas faire
mais je peux normalement l'attelage donc
entre la construction des voitures le
adaptation du matériel qu'on a fait ici
sur place après un petit peu termes plus
feutrés sage des chevaux qui est la base
d'attaché panon discipline particulière
les figures de dressage traditionnels
comme le carrousel lusitaniens sont
toujours présentes
elle se mêle à d'autres disciplines
comme les scream le kyodo de tir à l'arc
japonais ou encore le champ il ya eu pas
mal d'évolutions dans les chorégraphies
que ce soit pour le travail aux longues
rênes le carrousel le trio après la
représentation les spectateurs se
pressent dans les écuries amateurs de
chevaux novices ils viennent parfois de
très loin pour voir le travail de
bartabas
j'ai réservé même billet sur tours elle
charrie ici exclusivement pour ça alors
si le spectacle vous tente les écuyers
leur nature offre chaque week-end de
représentation le samedi à 18h ou le
dimanche à 15 heures
et cette année le centre social du pont
du rotois raguy en cours a voulu créer
une dynamique autour du développement
durable
les équipes proposent notamment des
ateliers de création de meubles en
carton récupération produits naturels et
imagination sont les ingrédients
nécessaires à la réalisation de cet
atelier original auquel nous avons
assisté
mélanie potiche pour ce reportage ouais
donc c'est vraiment au millimètre près
quoi pas au millimètre mais là le départ
il faut vraiment qu'on trois plaques
sera rentable roy un simple carton mais
beaucoup de précision c'est guillon
courtois ont décidé de se lancer dans la
fabrication de meubles dans une matière
inédite
c'est le carton de récupération c'était
le but de notre démarche c'était que de
faire des meubles à partir de cartons
qu'on trouvait qu'on récupère et dans
les magasins on n'a rien acheté
il a par plus tard le papier pour coller
la peinture mais pour l'instant on track
avec des matériaux de récupération
le carton est un matériau bien plus
solide qu'on ne l'imaginent puisqu'il
peut supporter jusqu'à 150 kg résistant
et biodégradable
quand on achète des meubles en kit en
fait ils sont tous en cartonné et le
fait de récupérer les cartons au lieu de
les déposer à la déchetterie pour en
faire des meubles trouve ça génial
notre structure est parti pour un projet
à long terme
en ce qui concerne le développement
durable
au sens large et l'atelier confection de
meubles en carton que en carton de
récupération et un atelier qui qui peut
sensibiliser les personnes et en même
temps avoir la satisfaction de garder un
meuble créé par eux-mêmes ces meubles
iront décorer leur habitation un autre
atelier devrait se faire au troisième
trimestre cette fois le gros mobilier
sera à l'honneur de quoi parfaire encore
sa technique est une idée de sortie pour
ces vacances scolaires le centre
commercial parly ii implantée au chesnay
a mis en place dans ses allées une
animation gratuite baptisée mini city le
concept les enfants âgés de 3 à 11 ans
encadrés par une dizaine d'animateurs
peuvent découvrir huit métiers jusqu'au
5 mars
on écoute tout de suite le directeur du
centre commercial parly 2 il était tôt
micro de michael oenning euros et de
fanny bourdillon on a recréé en fait 8
univers pour huit grands métiers dans
lequel les enfants peuvent interpréter
les rôles 1 est vraiment faire de
l'immersion dans un environnement qui
représente un lieu de travail et un
carnet véritablement des rollin et
développer leur propre scénario
derrière nous nous avons un atelier
chantier de construction donc là vous
voyez que les enfants peuvent se
déguiser mettre un casque de chantier
mettre un chef une chasuble construire
un mur avec des briques en mousse
construire un toit en tuiles et
découvrir l'ensemble des métiers sur un
chantier donc le conducteur de travaux
le designer architecte ainsi de suite
et nous recevons à présent sur notre
plateau notre journaliste sportif et
mickaël elle me d'euros pour sa
traditionnelle chronique du sport du jeu
dit bonsoir michael alors de quoi allez
vous nous parler aujourd'hui
bonsoir fin c'est toujours un plaisir de
vous retrouver le jeudi sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui nous allons parler football
et le de l'équipe senior de versailles
les joueurs de la cité royale pointe
actuellement à la 4e place du
championnat avec un match en moins en
division honneur
la première place occupée par l'équipe
de créteil lusitanos synonyme de montée
à 14 points l'accession à l'échelon
supérieur l'objectif fixé en début de
saison paraît donc plus que compromis
mais l'entraîneur de l'équipe et youssef
chibi veut toujours y croire on les
écoute je pense
jouable rien n'est fait il reste onze
matches de championnat mais aussi
créteil gagnent ce match est que l
afrique la vence rien n'est fait rien
n'est fait le champagne est encore long
les équipes vendront chèrement leur peau
que ce soit pour le maintien ou pour une
place honorable donc donc j'ai bon
espoir par rapport à ça et personne ne
lâchera rien l'équipe qui affiche un
bilan de 8 victoires 5 nuls et 2
défaites depuis le début de la saison
devra impérativement faire un sans faute
sur les 8 dernières journées du
championnat
la différence c'est les provinces et les
provinces et à dire que ne pas perdre
des points face à en route face à des
équipes à priori moins forts notamment à
domicile
donc nous on a perdu quelques matches
chez nous un match chez nous et quelques
nuls l'essai en cours de route
espérons qu'ils nous paient ne seront
pas sur la fin de championnat et ben
voilà ensuite les séries la série la loi
des séries c'est à dire pouvoir
enchaîner trois quatre cinq victoires
consécutives qui lui permet de se
détacher de ce qui se passe derrière et
se rapproche un peu plus de la première
place g us et chibi à la tête de
l'équipe seniors ii verset depuis
seulement deux saisons estime qu'il
faudra encore du temps à l'équipe pour
monter au niveau fédéral ça fait un an
et demi que je suis au club avec une un
changement important de l'effectif
encore un renouvellement on a rajeuni
l'effectif
donc je pense que pour aboutir à des
résultats il faut trois ans pense qu'il
faut trois ans on à mi-chemin par
rapport au travail qui a été réalisé
avec
la volonté de recréer une dynamique pour
pouvoir essayer de passer à l'échelon
supérieur
crucial non crucial non puisque les
bases sont saines au pour continuer de
rêver à l'échelon supérieur versailles
doit s'imposer à l'extérieur ce dimanche
sur le terrain de la garenne colombes un
choc dans ce championnat de dh les
versets sont 4e les joueurs des
hauts-de-seine sont cinquièmes la
rencontre risque d'être tendu pour ce
sprint final il y aura forcément du
suspens comme ça qu'on aime le football
à michael on passe à présent rendez vous
sportif à ne pas manquer ce week-end
dans les yvelines il y aura notamment du
football mais là du football américain
oui floral les templiers d'elancourt et
leur américain geass série dès qu'ils
reçoivent les redoutables dauphins de
nice ce samedi au complexe sportif
europe
c'est un petit peu l'histoire de david
contre goliath les templiers possède le
plus petit budget du championnat élite
la plus haute division française alors
que nice est l'un des plus gros budget
pour l'instant les deux équipes ne sont
séparées que par un petit point au
classement un résultat positif ce samedi
donc indispensable pour les élans
courtois donc vous la remettez la
pression et oui mickaël on termine par
un autre sport de contact le rugby un
match pour rester en vie dans ce
championnat de fédérale 3 chevreuse à la
lutte pour le maintien reçoit chinon
dernier du classement ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade municipal de chevreuse
les chevrotins coachée par brice trân
trong doivent l'emporter pour prendre
leurs distances sur joué-lès-tours
premier relégable les yvelinois compte
sur le soutien de leur public pour
réussir cet exploit
vous connaissez désormais les rendez
vous à ne pas manquer ce week-end
florane notre petite chronique
hebdomadaire s'achève on se retrouve à
la semaine prochaine mais calais les
téléspectateurs eux vont vous retrouvez
à lundi pour votre cette histoire quel
sera le programme alors nous parlerons
du tennis on disparaît que johan guillou
qui participera peut-être aux jeux
olympiques l'été prochain à rio et nous
parlons évidemment du match des
templiers d'elancourt contre les
dauphins de nice car vos programmes j'ai
hâte à michael merci beaucoup
et maintenant vous allez nous allons
aller au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je sais que
vous aimez beaucoup à cet endroit celui
tout le temps vous y allez tout le temps
c'est vrai ce mercredi donc le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
était en opération séduction les
responsables de vélo police la société
d'exploitation commerciale de la
structure ont présenté l'enceinte
sportive aux fédérations françaises une
vingtaine de représentants étaient
présents pour visiter les installations
parmi
la boxe la gymnastique et le volleyball
objectifs de l'événement créé des
partenariats entre les volets le
vélodrome et les fédérations dans les
prochaines années à écouter les
réactions
c'est important un pour faire vivre le
mauvais drôme de façon plus en plus
important parce que les éléments vélos
sont importants mais au maximum on en
aura peut-être 15 par an et ce sera déjà
beaucoup donc en plus de ça il faut
qu'on puisse récupérer 5 des 10
événements en dehors du vélo ce soit du
judo de jeudi va revenir au mois de mai
les 28 et 29 mai il ya le vent la lutte
qui intéressait j'espère qu'ils vont
venir
c'est une journée qui est intéressante
pour tous les partis et aussi pour vélos
police parce qu'il faut faire connaître
cet équipement qui al air câlin des
équipements dédiés à tout type
d'événement scier le sportif ou non par
ailleurs et c'est la fin de cette
édition je vous remercie nous avoir
suivis demain vous avez rendez vous avec
le wild friederici pour l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine
mélanie peau qui vous donnera des idées
de sorties pour vos vacances avec le 7 8
le week-end quand à moi je vous retrouve
lundi pour un nouveau numéro du journal
je vous souhaite donc une excellente
soirée et un très bon week end